South Africa have won the Rugby World
Cup the Springboks defeated England 32
12 in the final in Yokohama Japan South
Africa took an early lead in the first
half with hundred Paulo kicking for
penalties however the English side made
it tight with their own penalty kicks
for a South African 12:6 halftime lead
the Springboks then took control in the
second half to win by 32 points to 12
and joining us now from Cape Town to
discuss the Rugby World Cup is DW
correspondent Adrian Krrish Adrian I
imagine the party's been full throttle
for about an hour now how important is
this title to South Africans absolutely
maybe you can hear it hooting people
moving around celebrating motorcades
moving around all over the place
this was such an important victory for
the country at the end of the day quite
a clear when I'm just coming from one of
the many pubs and bars that were totally
overcrowded today in the mood there was
of course very good people told me that
this is exactly what this country needed
after weeks of rather negative news bad
economy xenophobic attacks this is
finally something positive getting out
of South Africa and it is a reason to
celebrate and the captain of the team
has said it right after the match quite
clearly he said we have so many problems
back home but we are showing the people
now what we can achieve and we all stand
together give us a sense of how this
sport ranked compared to say football I
mean football still has a bigger
supporter base I would say but rugby has
been going through an interesting
transformation it's been seen as the
sports of the white minority of the
white oppressors during the time of
apartheid but then in 1995 when Nelson
Mandela was the president already the
World Cup took place right here in South
Africa and South Africa won this was a
unifying moment for this country that
brought people together and many people
are hoping that today is a similar
situation originally the perception is
of a white sport but South Africa is
looking more and more like a truly
multiracial squad do people there talk
about that
well they do and rugby is still White's
dominated but really as I said there was
a tremendous transformation that is
still ongoing but there's one person one
character who really shows the this
transformation and that is siiiick Oh
luli the captain of the team the first
black captain of the Springboks he's
such a strong role model for the kids
here he's somebody who stands for this
new South Africa not for the old one a
young generation is married to a white
woman but he doesn't even want to talk
much about this white black things
anymore he says we just have to look
forward and work together as a country
and I think this is a very powerful and
important message that this country
needs at this point of time
Adrian chrétien south edge of Africa
first thank you so so much